Salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésor, alors aujourd'hui on est au château Lancyre, dans le haut Languedoc.
C'est un des plus gros châteaux du coin.
Nous voilà donc à la première marre du château, donc plutôt sympa, je pense qu'on va jeter les aimants,
il y a peut-être des petits trésors là-dedans, et en parlant de trésors il y en a un deuxième
qui se cache peut-être dans ma main, enfin le trésor, si on réussit à résoudre les énigmes,
puisqu'en effet on est en partenariat avec l'élixir d'or qui nous a offert ce parchemin
et qui a caché un trésor d'une valeur de 100 000 euros quelque part en France,
donc 100 000 euros, pas en cash, mais en bouteilles de vin.
Pourquoi en bouteilles de vin ? Là ça y est, vous comprenez pourquoi on est ici.
Cette chasse aux trésors a été créée en partenariat avec 43 domaines viticoles dans toute la France.
Je vais pas spoil les énigmes.
Alors vous avez un parchemin avec 6 énigmes, et l'objectif est de déchiffrer ces énigmes.
C'est une chasse aux trésors, la chasse aux trésors se déroule à distance,
donc vous n'avez pas besoin de vous déplacer,
vous n'avez pas besoin non plus d'avoir de matériel spécifique tels que des aimants ou des détecteurs.
Vous pouvez faire votre chasse aux trésors depuis la maison en résolvant ces énigmes-là.
Voici la cave à gagner et sa composition,
et vous avez ici le château de l'ancière qui nous accueille aujourd'hui pour pécher à l'aiement.
Un grand merci à eux.
Si vous voulez participer à cette chasse aux trésors,
le droit d'entrée c'est ce parchemin que vous retrouverez sur le site.
Vous avez le code promo Pecheurdetresor10 qui vous offre 10% sur toute la boute.
C'est un quoi ça ?
C'est un crapeau buffle.
Qui vous offre moins 10% sur l'achat du parchemin,
et il existe aussi une forme dématérialisée en e-book.
Maintenant je vais vous laisser à mon compagnie de Chloé qui va vous parler du château l'ancière.
Bonjour, donc je suis chargée de communication et de œnotourisme au domaine,
et le château Lancyre donc c'est un domaine viticole de 80 hectares en pique Saint-Loup,
géré par la famille Valentin Durand,
et ici on produit une dizaine de cuvées en bio et HVE.
Ok, ok, super, et vous participez donc au projet,
vous avez donc apporté des bouteilles, c'est ça ?
Tout à fait, donc nous vous pouvez retrouver dans la cave finale 4 cuvées à nous,
des cuvées qui peuvent se garder,
puisqu'on ne sait pas quand est-ce que sera trouvée la cave finale.
Donc on est sur des cuvées blanc et rouge qui peuvent se garder 10, 15, voire 20 ans,
et que le gagnant pourra déguster quand il le trouvera,
ou encore dans quelques années.
J'ai regardé toutes les règles du concours,
vous avez jusqu'à 2028 pour trouver l'énigme
Si elle n'est pas trouvée avant, les 100 000 euros seront offert à une association
Et la cave est actuellement exposée au château de Vaux le Vicomte
où toutes les bouteilles sont réunies, donc vous pouvez aller les voir dès maintenant.
Ouais, vous avez toutes les infos sur le site, il est très bien fait,
n'hésitez pas à les jeter un oeil
Bon Quentin on pêche maintenant ?
Allez, c'est parti, Rasta t'es prêt ?
Il paraît qu'il y a des lingots d'or dans ce lac, c'est ça ?
Ça fait très longtemps qu'on l'a pas exploré.
Ah ouais, bon, on va voir.
Est-ce que l'équipe d'Elixir d'or n'aurait pas fait une blague et caché le trésor ici ?
Ah, ça serait drôle.
Sans faire les enigmes.
Comment il s'appelle ce lac ?
Alors, pour la petite anecdote, ce lac s'appelle le Lac des figuiers,
et il s'agit maintenant du nom, le nom d'une cuvée de rosé,
qu'on a retravaillé un petit peu, on a refait l'étiquette et le nom,
et on voulait parler de lac, parce qu'on a quand même plusieurs lacs sur le domaine.
Sympa.
Si on trouve rien, est-ce qu'on peut repartir avec une bouteille de rosé ?
A voir... (oui)
Vous êtes prêts pour le premier lancier ?
Ouais, les prêts.
C'est le plus important.
Je vais essayer de tirer quand même par-dessus l'arbre.
Ouais, vas-y, on tire l'arbre, c'est pas grave.
Parf le crapeau.
Il ne doit pas y avoir grand-chose, mais rien que si on trouve des...
Ouais, rien que du vieux matériel agricole, ça peut être sympa.
Ouais, s'il y aura des choses, ce sera ancien.
Ouais.
En tout cas, le cadre est très beau, là, vous pouvez apercevoir le pique Saint-Lou, là-haut.
Eh ben, j'ai l'impression qu'on n'a pas grand-chose.
C'est propre pour l'instant.
On va aller voir là-bas.
Ouais, il faudrait au moins une trouvaille.
Ouais.
Tu ne pars pas tant que tu n'en as pas fait une
Ouais, alors ?
Il y a quelque chose.
Ah !
Mais ça a l'air gros parce que là, tu vois, ça me...
Ouais ?
Ouais, il y a un vrai truc aimenté.
Ah, mais c'est étonnant, hein.
Mais je pense qu'il va...
Je ne sais pas s'il va venir.
Tu vas te voir y aller, peut-être ?
Peut-être qu'il va falloir y aller, c'est ce que je t'ai en train de penser.
Rasta, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Toi, tu es l'expert.
Aimenté, ouais.
Oh oui, ça t'as entendu ?
Ouais.
Tu veux y aller ?
Je peux essayer.
Tu as des chaussures un peu mieux ?
Non, comme ça.
Tu peux y aller comme ça ?
Ouais.
T'auras le droit de rentrer dans la cave après ?
Ouais pieds nus
Non, faut pas que je mouille mon short
Non, mais là, tu peux y aller sans mouiller ton short
C'est pas profond.
Au moins, il y a quelque chose.
Déjà, dans une mare comme ça, c'était pas gagné, hein.
Ça va, mais en vrai, il vient de pleuvoir, donc l'eau n'est pas trop chaude.
Oui, rassure sur toi comme tu peux.
Ah purée je dois enlever le t-shirt
La baignade dans la mare
Ah ouais
Alors ?
Alors attends.
Oh !
Un vieux piquet
C'est pas jeune, ça, hein ?
Non.
Bah voilà.
Au moins, je vais continuer à lancer, mais c'est bien, hein.
Ouais.
C'est bizarre qu'ils ne sont pas venus.
Voilà, le trésor tiens
Je sais pas si tu veux te salir les mains ou pas, mais c'est un peu sale.
Ouais, c'est un peu sale.
Voilà.
Peut-être qu'ils avaient une petite barque, qu'ils attachaient une barque, je sais pas.
Ouais.
Il faut se dire qu'à l'époque, il y avait sûrement beaucoup plus d'eau dans le coin.
Allez, tiens, je vais continuer à lancer.
Allez.
Premier trésor.
Ouais.
Déjà bien, le petit piquet, là.
Ouais, ouais.
Après, vous inquiétez pas, on a des idées en tête pour aller pêcher à d'autres endroits pas loin,
qui ont l'air très prometteurs aussi.
Ouais, on va aller au canal le plus proche du domaine.
Donc, vous verrez bien.
L'adresse et le site du domaine seront eux aussi en description de la vidéo,
si vous voulez du vin.
Ouais, parce que pour pêcher les mains dans le lac, on ne conseille pas.
Ouais, pas besoin évitez
Bon, mais un piquet !
Le lac du domaine est propre.
Voilà ce qu'on a pêché, donc...
Ouais, il était dans l'étang
Ouais.
Du coup, on a gagné une bouteille, là.
Au plus bon, le vin.
Non, 1984 ça commence à faire loin
Ouais.
Alors là, ça commence très bien.
Quand un perdu son aimant dans l'eau dès son premier lancer,
il a oublié de l'attacher à un point fixe.
Deuxième lancer.
J'ai déjà trouvé une pièce de 1 centime
Ah.
Deuxième lancer et il commence à pleuvoir.
Tiens l'autre côté parce que si on perd les deux ça va être chiant
Non, on va l'attacher à un point fixe, comme on fait toujours.
T'inquiète.
Encore une pièce
Ah, tu vois, ouais.
Il y a peut-être une caisse quelque part, alors.
Oh.
Portugal, je crois.
Et oui, Quentin dit encore les pays,
même quand c'est des pièces en euros.
C'est pas marrant si je dis que c'est juste 5 centimes d'euros
Et du coup, à chaque fois, je crois que c'est des pièces intéressantes,
c'est des centimes.
Ah, il a repéré avec la corde et pas avec l'aimant
Non l'aimant était trop loin
Bon, bah écoute, c'est bien.
C'est un bon début, on a trouvé un aimant.
Deux pièces, une sur l'autre.
Et du coup, elles sont neuves de ce côté
Ah ouais.
L'autre côté, il est détruit.
Mais pour moi, c'est pas normal qu'il y ait autant de pièces ici,
parce que c'est pas un endroit où tu fais des vœux.
Ah, il devait y avoir un coffre.
Ouais.
Allez, on continue, alors.
Hop, le lancer.
Magnifique de Quentin.
Je crois que j'ai un sachet ou une barquette.
Ah, c'est quoi ce bordel ?
Ah, c'est de la bonne dépollution du plastique.
Ouais, mais c'est coincé comment ?
Ah, une pièce.
Cinq centimes encore.
Ça va.
Mais garde-les en vrai, ça en fait beaucoup là.
Tu les as mis ou les tiens ?
Dans ma poche
Ah, ah, ah.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Nice !
Je vous ai fait le fameux nice, parce que ça j'aime bien.
Est-ce que c'est un Laguiole ?
Bon, il a pris cher, il manque le bois et tout ça,
mais ça doit être un laguiole
Oui, c'est un laguiole
Bon là, il faudra trouver du bois de rechange.
Moi, j'ai fait ça, ça a un morceau de voiture, je crois,
mais une sorte de résistance Mitsubishi.
C'est...
Ouais, je sais pas, ouais.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Ça vient, Quentin.
Tu es prêt mon pote ?
Ouais.
J'aime bien le poids.
Voyons voir ce que ce canal nous a offert.
Oh, c'est intéressant ça.
Putain, c'est une scotch.
Oui, c'est bien une scotch.
Pardon pour le gros mot, mais...
Ah là, ça sent le truc de ouf, là.
Oh, purée, c'est de la drogue ou quoi ?
Oh, c'est des pièces !
Oh, c'est des pièces, ouais.
Bien joué.
C'est rempli d'argent.
Vous voyez, on a trouvé notre propre trésor.
Oh, c'est incroyable.
On est ici depuis 5 minutes.
On vous a parlé de trésor tout à l'heure.
On trace tout droit, on vient voir un spot et on trouve un trésor.
Mais c'est dingue.
Ouais.
Oh, j'adore.
Magnifique.
Ok, les gars, c'est vraiment pour ce genre de découverte qu'on fait ça,
et c'est vraiment ces découvertes-là qu'on adore partager avec vous.
Enlève l'aimant, je pense d'abord, ouais.
On va placer...
Oh, mais c'est une dingue.
La quantité de pièces qu'il devrait avoir.
J'espère qu'il y a des 1 et 2 euros, quand même.
Oh, c'est lourd.
C'est hyper lourd.
C'est dingue.
Ah, tu sentais ou pas que c'était quelque chose dedans ?
Oh, il est rempli.
Rempli, rempli de pièces.
Ils sont bien conservés, du coup.
Eh oui.
Oh, ça va en mettre partout, par contre, si je l'ouvre.
Oh, la quantité.
C'est les restes d'un casse je pense
D'un cambriolage
La quantité.
Combien il doit y avoir ?
On continue d'ouvrir à la maison pour pas en mettre partout ?
Ouais, on compte à la maison.
On vous met la suite de l'ouverture, à la maison.
Oh, la quantité.
Regarde, magnifique.
Voilà, du coup, ça a bien mordu.
Et on sent que OH... il y a encore d'autres choses.
C'est peut-être d'autres balouchons.
Moi, je dis que c'est possible parce que j'en ai senti, je me suis promené quand je tirais à côté.
Quentin, je suis persuadé qu'il y en a d'autres des balouchons remplis de pièces.
Et ils sont juste en face.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, dommages.
OK.
Ah ben ça, c'est ça, c'est le truc auquel tu es attaché, ouais.
Vous êtes de plus en plus à nous regarder,
et depuis un peu partout dans le monde, donc ça, ça nous fait très plaisir.
Spéciales dédicaces aujourd'hui à tous ceux qui sont en Nouvelle Calédonie ou à Mayotte.
Cet aimant, là, c'est pour vous.
Enfin, le lancer, l'aimant je le garde.
Allez, on va voir ce qu'on a trouvé.
Ah ça, ça vient d'un outil, non ?
Oui.
Ouais.
Il vient ?
Ouais, il vient.
Vas-y, hein.
Tu paries sur quoi ?
Est-ce que ça peut être un cadre ?
Non, je dis peut-être un vélo.
Ouais, c'est possible.
Mais en plus, tu dis ça parce qu'il y a la piste cyclable en face
Ouais.
Un moteur.
Ah, c'est un moteur de quoi, ça ?
De scooters, ou quoi ?
Mais je sais même pas si c'est pas un truc de tondeuse ou quoi, non ?
Ah, peut-être de scooter.
Bah, si vous savez en commentaire, mais...
Ouais, n'hésitez pas à nous dire plus d'infos en commentaire.
En tout cas, bien joué d'avoir ramené ça jusqu'au bout.
C'est une bonne dépollution encore ça
Et pour le coup, effectivement, il n'est pas jeune.
C'est juste qu'il a été loupé par les autres pêcheurs à l'aimant
C'est ça.
Il était l'autre côté.
Voilà.
Bah, je préfère ma trouvaille à moi, mais c'est pas mal.
Ah, dommage.
Dommage.
C'est quoi, une sorte de...
Un crochet, ouais.
C'est un outil, je pense.
Ça peut servir.
Ouais, ça aurait pu être pire.
Quand tu renvoies ta corde dans l'eau, comme tout à l'heure ?
Ouais.
Ouais, il te faudrait un manche, ouais.
Tu en penses quoi ?
Bah, il reste des choses, mais la plupart sont récentes ou bien dans la vase.
Des fois, en changeant un peu les angles, on arrive à les avoir.
C'est vrai.
Donc, l'avantage, si c'est un canal où il y a des choses intéressantes.
Donc, dans tous les cas, dès qu'on a quelque chose, on est contents
Bon, je me suis moqué deQuentin et j'ai jeté mon aimant, moi aussi, dans l'eau, avec toute la corde.
Alors, pour ma défense, moi, je l'avais attaché là-dessus.
Mais va la chercher
Pourquoi prendre l'aimant quand on peut y aller avec les mains
Il y a quelque chose, là ?
Dans les herbes.
Oula.
C'est quoi, ça ?
C'est une branche ?
Non, je l'ai, non ?
Non, c'est du fil de fer...
Là, tu vas t'amuser pour décrocher ça.
Ah, la trouvaille de merde !
Bon, je me suis décalé entre les deux ponts.
J'ai rampé sous celui-là.
Et il y aura plus de choses, je pense que ce sera moins fait.
Désolé pour le bruit des voitures.
Appelle Rasta, Quentin.
Appelle Rasta.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais, Rasta, sur le pont ?
Ah oui, t'as eu peur, Rasta, mais t'as y qu'à pas aller sur le pont.
Là, j'ai eu quelque chose sous le pont.
Qui est assez lourd.
Ah, je suis coincé.
Ah !
Il faut le treuil.
Vous changez d'endroit.
C'est lourd.
C'est une mobilette.
C'est Peugeot 103, je crois.
Ça fait un moment qu'elle est là, celle-là.
Bien joué.
Merci.
Il y a encore la béquille et il y a une pédale.
Ah, elle est morte.
Elle part en lambeaux.
Allez, on va voir ce qu'on arrive à attraper
Ah !
Munition de AK, je pense.
Je crois que ça vient d'un AK-47, ça.
Ah ben, je vais continuer, alors.
On va voir ce que c'est ensemble.
Oui.
Oh, yes !
Yes !
J'adore !
Il est super beau.
Enfin, elle est super belle, c'est une masse.
Et le manche est en bois, franchement, c'est superbe.
J'ai quelque chose.
Ah, je suis obligé de descendre.
Ah, c'est un...
Ah ben, je pense que c'est le phare.
Le tour de phare de ma moto.
Ouais.
Oh !
What ?
Oh la la la, c'est de la voiture, tout ça.
Allez, sois gentil.
Arrête de faire le toboggan.
Yes !
Je l'ai.
Je l'ai, je l'ai, je l'ai.
Et ça, les gars, gros morceaux de plastoc, hein.
Et là, regardez les gars, une pince
Je me suis mis de l'autre côté du pont en face de Baptiste.
Je pense qu'on va trouver avec notre aimant.
Et ça a l'air d'être de la qualité en plus.
Oh oui, elle s'ouvre.
Ouais, bon, elle a pris cher un peu.
Il va falloir un peu de WD-40 là, parce que...
Elle est assez dure, mais...
Elle devrait fonctionner.
Ok.
Une chaine.
Une chaine, une chaine.
Mais malheureusement, en acier.
Regarde Baptiste, elle vole.
Là, il y a un problème, là.
Viens m'aider
Je vais le rejoindre ou je vais pas le rejoindre ?
Allez, j'arrive.
Ok, j'ai réussi à rejoindre Quentin de l'autre côté.
Il voyait les traces d'aiement.
Il a réussi quand même à le faire traîner jusque-là.
Mais pas à le décrocher.
Il faut savoir que c'est le barbariande 1600 kg de chez Maison de la détection.
Et ça, quand c'est vraiment sur de la fonte pure,
il faut y aller.
Là, ça fait quelques semaines, enfin, quelques mois,
qu'on a repris la muscu.
On va essayer.
On va retourner la casquette.
Franchement, si t'arrives sur le gros respect,
déjà, il faut que tu fasses un angle de côté, je pense.
Tu tires, par exemple, genre comme ça,
à un coup sec.
Mais vraiment, il faut y aller tout donner.
Vous êtes prêts ?
Ouais.
Presque.
Vous êtes prêts ?
Prêts.
C'est sans doute que c'était galère, non ?
Ouais, ça m'a fait un peu mal au main.
Ouais, par exemple.
Bravo.
C'est fait.
Donc, ça passe.
Vous voyez, quand vous êtes musclé,
le barbarien, ça fait le taf.
Sinon, on conseille quand même le terror
pour commencer doucement.
Ouais, bah c'est surtout parce que là,
ça va, c'est hors de l'eau.
Mais si c'est pareil, au fond de l'eau,
sur notre Instagram,
qui est en description de la vidéo,
et qui s'affiche ici.
Ça va être plus compliqué
de prévu de compter, je pense.
Oh, des clés.
On a un côté épais,
on va être sûr qu'il y a rien.
C'est du scotch et des sachets.
Ça va être génial de compter tout ça.
Ouais, c'est un plaisir.
On va s'amuser.
Regarde la quantité.
On espère que vous avez apprécié
cette vidéo.
Rasta a apprécié en tout cas.
Il a apprécié.
Rasta assis
Il est ou le trésor ?
On espère que vous avez apprécié les découvertes, mais vraiment ce baluchon j'ai adoré
même s'il était pas rempli de C.
Il était quand même bien rempli.
On va revenir sur ce spot.
Il y a encore pas mal de distances à faire.
N'hésitez pas, donc,
à aller sur les liens en description
pour le parchemin
et pour trouver le trésor
avec les bouteilles de vin.
Et à vous abonner.
Ouais, et à vous abonner.
Nous, je pense qu'aujourd'hui,
on va rentrer.
Bon, douche et tout.
Et puis, on va commencer